a nice pairing with
black against krup that's Grandmaster
Krupa actually from the Ukraine where
the flag stands for
Jordan maybe he works there as a
trainer somehow so now
we have Catalan here he also plays
Knight E5 not Queen C2 yes I have that
Yes, I've tried this somewhat strange
variant more than once so far
with
pretty good
success. Let's see if the
grandmaster can show me why that's bad.
So I think it's very
likely
that you can show something with
white against, but I don't know  exactly what
it
is that looks more dangerous
tur D4 knight
B5
H
C6 is a move that you don't
want to play here, it
actually seems very
passive but that's an unpleasant
move okay not the dream
but I can't see anything else
against it right now  That could
be the problem that he's really catching up with E4
here quickly,
so we're trying to
catch up a little bit in terms of development, so the question now is whether I should
try to get
a little activity here, of
course it's very weakening,
admittedly,
but you can  Don't just
stand here passively the whole time, then
you'll just be carried away by the
center, so on d5 I'd
probably still have knight C5 as an
answer, so maybe something like
that isn't a direct threat yet
But of course
D5 is always
an answer that
can be unpleasant. I'll do it here. The idea here
is to play knight C4,
of course, with the
clamped dme on A6
everything looks a bit strange,
so I'm surprised now  not
if White had something good
so
okay so he chooses a simple
continuation which doesn't mean it's
bad
well I
might have that so I think I think
I should play like that rather than
swapping the knights to have knight C4
yes okay I have that  Of course I
saw it but couldn't do anything about it,
so maybe you can swap
and what does the move look like Queen A4 or does
he have a really stupid Queen E7 and
I don't have a sensible move it
could be Queen A4 Queen
E7 tur D7 Queen E8 mate
and Queen
E7
Bishop D7 but then I can play it
then it didn't do that much good let's take
a look actually it did
n't do that much good either admittedly well yes
that's ä that's just
difficult against grandmasters if you
don't have the right variants  knows and
and relies on some kind of
side trip here which
is really second class then
you rarely really get out of it
so well once
pushed like Springer G4 might be an idea now
also yes I'll do the air hole even
if of course it's a stable template
is for possible victims and now
D A3
to prevent to take the toe here
so okay he might want to
do something straight away but then I have
Queen F8 to
help here, I'm not quite sure if that's
the right plan  for white or whether
you shouldn't have tried to play completely
dry on the queenside
rook E1 yes tur E3 F3 would
definitely like to try so yes I ca
n't do much about that either
but I can
at least
put myself in here and maybe myself  sometimes by with
sometimes relieve by
exchange
so I don't quite understand F4 F5
maybe he wants to do
well knight to F4 or something good I do
n't have a
great other plan here anyway than to move forward on the dm wing
Queen G4 and then knight H5
okay it's bad  I don't know yet,
I don't yet see what exactly is bad about it,
so
I just saw that the quality was casually sacrificed, I
thought it would
work somehow. This was probably
nonsense because I think I was actually out of the worst of it
hm yes that was that was too too
impulsive unfortunately it's not enough here the
pawn is me, well
you can
still fight with knight A4 I can
maybe even cover him
oh the cheap trick yes yes yes he's
right of course yes I can  Don't do anything
Task,
yes, that was stupid. I really
should have just pulled the rook back.
I somehow thought so impulsively that
by clearing it you would have
done something. I also had to put a little pressure on the clock if I
moved back to C7 now, I don't know
I think he didn't play that well before,
it cost a lot of time
on the kingside, there
was simply no pushing and attacking,
so the position ca
n't actually be that bad for Black now,
I can't imagine it, so it's
certain that the position
would be worse at some point  I say it's a
shame